know our game is founded on grass you
know it's a football stadium they come
and see football players there yeah they
can have like concerts and stuff there
but they they change it for soccer
players when they come soccer players
when they come over here and play they
never play on astro turf wow or
artificial grass they always wheel in
natural grass for them to play in and
then they take it off when they leave we
the ones in there I mean we're the ones
in there playing so I feel like the game
was founded on the grass so every
Stadium should be on grab it's gonna be
I think it's going to be a little bit of
a shift too like now uh that's a very
significant injury last night with Aaron
Rodgers as big the biggest one the
biggest stars in sports so stuff like
that causes for a change but it's
ironically I'm not going to speak out of
term but I can vividly remember multiple
guys getting hurt on in MetLife and on
that specific Turf and other guys kind
of commenting throughout the years of a
guy getting hurt on that Turf and like
that's just some bad turf or that
whatever the reason is or whatever the
reason I heard they new Turf this year
but Turf in general if you can try to
eradicate or get rid of injuries for the
most part it's already you already gonna
get hurt at one point doing something if
you can kind of get rid of those small
tissues or those injuries that you know
kind of might not take place if we got a
slippery or like a better surface I
think I think I think Aaron Rodgers
would definitely be the Catalyst to get
everything changed for sure